[Music]
this is the ramsay show
[Applause]
you can be intentional about your
character you can have money and a
career you are the hero in your story
live from the headquarters of ramsey
solutions it's the ramsey show where
debt is dumb cash is king and the paid
off home mortgage has taken the place of
the bmw as the status symbol of choice
we help people build wealth do work that
they really love and create actual
amazing relationships george campbell
ramsey personality host of the fine
print one of our podcasts on the ramsey
networks is my co-host today as we
answer your questions about your life
and your money the phone number is
triple eight eight two five five two two
five the call is free and some say the
advice is worth exactly what you pay for
it triple eight eight two five five two
two five brent is going to start off
this hour in akron ohio hi brent how are
you
hi dave thanks for taking my call sure
um
what i am wondering i've never heard
anybody ask something like this before
is my wife and i have saved up
a good chunk of money to build a house
but until we get the rest of the savings
taken care of for building the house
we're wondering would it be a
bad idea
to purchase a
rental property or just an investment
property
and hold on to it for the next say
three four maybe five years until we get
the rest of our savings for building the
house
and then where are you living property
where are you living
uh we are in a rental
um
why would you buy an investment property
why wouldn't you buy something to live
in
because
we are at a
we pay about half the going rate of
the
rate around our area we actually rent
from family
and we've been here about 25 years
we like where we're at
and we have property to build on
already we already own the property
so we're just waiting to
get the rest of the money to build all
right so how much money have you got
right now
we got about 320 000 saved what's your
need
probably
originally it was probably going to be
about 400 and then covet hit now it's
probably going to be
five
maybe five fifty what do you make i told
income
um we bring in around before taxes
around 120.
okay so how long is it gonna take you to
get this other 180
i'm figuring probably at least three
years yeah three or four is what i
thought
what's the purpose of buying the rental
property right now
just because right now we've got that
money parked in a money market account
but the
we're only getting like half a percent
right now yeah and what we were thinking
is if we did that for a couple of years
and resell it
we would get more of a return on that
money
than what we will get over that course
of time in the money market account
there's just a lot of risk in in there's
you're looking at all of the upside and
none of the downside with this rental
property situation
yeah the problem with real estate is
that it's sometimes hard to get out of
it's still it's an illiquid investment
okay you can't just decide i'm gonna
sell it now for the last three or four
years you can just decide you're gonna
sell a house and it's gone in 30 days
but that's not been a normal
way of doing real estate
except that's an unusual three-year
period okay and if we go back if we go
into a slower real estate market which i
think we're going to
um
then you know you might have trouble
getting out of that thing when you want
to
uh
you know and you don't want it and
there's a word there's a word for real
estate that sells really fast cheap
you give it away because you need the
money right and then all your theory of
making money goes out the window i
probably i love real estate
but i probably wouldn't do that i think
you're adding a lot of hassle to your
life um i would move some of the money
into probably an index fund just that is
liquid in other words you can cash it
out anytime you want but you're going to
make more than a half a percent over
three years index fund follows the the
stock market and
you know uh i think over the next three
or four years you're gonna make some
money in that i better and a half a
percent for sure
i've got a bunch of money in that
myself and so um obviously i do believe
that that's what's happening so
um but i you know if you don't wanna
move it all in there and maybe half of
it and you at least you'll make
something on it but i just i i'm not
gonna
the re i don't i'm not worried about the
investment property going down in value
i'm worried about the market slowing
down and you can't get out of it as
quickly as you need to when you're
finally ready to build this dream house
after 25 years of rent yeah you've got a
specific timeline you're looking for to
do this in the next three years it just
feels like there's too much on the line
yeah just to make a little money on it
and so if you make 10 on 300 000 it's 30
000 bucks 30 000 bucks does not solve
this problem
it just keeps you from being aggravated
making no money in a money market that's
all it does
so um i'm gonna move some of it or all
of it into an index fund but i don't
think i would do real estate in this
case because i don't know how quickly
the house is going to sell it's a great
long-term investment but in the short
term it could be volatile i like the
market we'll say we've said it over and
over and over for past three or four
weeks but um
it bears saying a lot more as a matter
of fact i think we're going to do an
event on this coming up we'll let y'all
know when and everything
but real estate's such a hot topic right
now there's so many things going on with
it but i am positive
okay
that real estate is not going to go down
in value in the next five years
some of you are going oh it's
artificially high it's going to go down
no it's not there's so much talk of the
crash right now there is not it's it's
simply not going to go down and let me
help you with this okay i've been doing
real estate for 30 years
it's a real simple equation
100
and i just taped the thing a few minutes
ago for the instagram goobies out there
with my with brooke who runs instagram
stuff but 100 of real estate prices is
based on supply demand
period
when there is more buyers than sellers
prices go up
when there is more sellers than buyers
prices go down now there's things that
affect how many buyers there are and how
many sellers there are but that's the
equation
you know inflation recession
stagflation idiots in the white house
high interest rates affect the number of
buyers
but unless the number of buyers goes
substantially below
the number of sellers
in the marketplace
you're not going to see prices go down
and we know that this is not going to
happen because it this year we have 128
million households in 2007 we had 116
million households 12 million more
households today that need houses in
2007 there were 2.1
million new housing starts
this year 1.4 million
the inventory available for sale of
houses right now is 50 of what it was in
2007.
supply
is drastically
short
versus demand
prices are not going down there is not
going to be a real estate crash there's
nothing in this equation that says
there's going to be a real estate crash
nothing
and you take it to the bank i've told
you some other stuff that came true like
i told you inflation was coming i tell
you stuff guys i've been doing this a
long time
i'm gonna wait on the house prices to go
down you're they're not going down
what goes up must go down you're wrong
this is the ramsey show
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
look i love real estate and i want you
to have a house but i don't want a house
to have
you
that's why you need to get in touch with
churchill mortgage to make sure you do
this right these guys are awesome
they'll help you get on a smarter
mortgage plan because they're committed
to doing what's right for
you
that means they check in every year with
free consultations to help you stay on
the right plan they show you how to save
money and interest so you can build
wealth faster they walk you through the
total cost of your loan so you can make
the best choice
basically they care that's why we call
them ramsey trusted
you can achieve debt-free home ownership
and churchill is here to help go to
their site
churchillmortgage.com ramsey to start
your approval or get more information
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
george campbell ramsey personality is my
co-host today michael is in daytona
beach hey michael how are you i'm
wonderful how are you better than i
deserve how can we help
uh yeah so um
i had a guy in a car accident about two
years ago and just now i'm finally
receiving the settlement
and instead of blowing it i want to try
to
invest in it and that's with it should i
say um after paying some debt off with
it um
i'll probably have like twenty thousand
dollars
but my big question is so i also owe on
my car
and that's about 500 a month i owe about
10 000
um so i'm wondering if i should take
that 10 000
and invest it and make money off of that
or should i just pay my car off um
and get rid of debt in general and then
but the problem is it's hard for me to
save money in general so do you have any
uh permanent
damage from their accident
oh yes i do have a
back i have a lower back injury so i'm
kind of limited to work sometimes
do you need some of the money to
continue medical
yeah so i'm thinking that um
i'm gonna keep about half of it uh keep
it in the account just for you know days
that i can't work um days uh you know
i'm having to pay for some type of
medical uh but uh and i'm thinking about
10
uh keeping about 10 of it for either
paying the car off or using uh to invest
and i was thinking about doing some
investment in like vending machines
but you know
doing it like new i mean i'm only going
to get about one vending machine and you
know if i'm watching making 600
a month off of that you know
how old are you michael
i am 35. okay and what's the settlement
amount
uh so i received about 33
uh but i have to
pay off some family debt when i got my
house um and there's
you know some things that i need to work
on my house uh some investment you know
fixing up my house uh doing some
gutter work and stuff like that
how much debt do you have total just
consumer debt non-mortgage
uh non-mortgage so i owe about ten
thousand dollars for the car
um
i do have another personal loan that i
owe
a few thousand dollars on i'm not
exactly sure haven't seen in a while
that just comes out of my bank account
like monthly so i've really looked at it
it's probably maybe three or four
thousand if i'm not mistaken
okay and how much is the family loan
i'm sorry how much is the family loan
uh what do you mean by family you said
you owed family some money
oh okay that's about thirty four hundred
dollars okay so i'm at sixteen four plus
the gutters are gonna be how much
it's about uh fifteen hundred dollars
okay so i'm gonna call it twenty
thousand it's gonna leave you thirteen
thousand after you pay off everything
is that all the money you have to your
name at that point
uh yes right now i've got about um i
haven't quite got up to what i'm uh paid
off yet but i've got about 27 in the
bank still
um so like i said about seven of that's
going to go towards the gutters and
27
27 000 or twenty seven hundred
thousand you said seven towards the
gutters but you just told us it's gonna
cost fifteen hundred
no fifteen hundred for the gutters
and then um about i think i said it was
uh either but it's either i think it's
34.
so you know plus i was just kind of like
giving a rough estimate okay here's what
i would do i would be debt free i would
set aside an emergency fund and no i
would not buy vending machines
i would think about what your new career
is going to be that doesn't strain your
back and if you need to take some
classes i'd spend some money on that to
work your new career that doesn't strain
your back you have an income problem
going forward and you're going to have
to get some discipline because you're
going to burn through the rest of this
money like nothing in two years and
you're gonna end up with nothing out of
this well i do work but uh
like uh
full i mean i work probably
close to 40 hours a week
yeah but you're setting money aside for
when you can't work which means you're
in the wrong job
you told me you want to set money aside
for when you can't work
that doesn't have a good plan over a
30-year period of time you're not going
to have this money for 30 years doing
that
so you need to create enough of an
income to live on and have enough
disciplined process in your budget where
you don't overspend what you have coming
in so you don't need any money except
for maybe a future
surgery because you have enough income
coming in and enough discipline on that
income to control it with a budget and
and living you know straight up on that
hold on we're gonna send you a copy of
the book the total money makeover which
has helped 10 million people do what
you're trying to do and if you'll read
it and do it it'll work i promise you
and restocking a vending machine sounds
like it would hurt my back exactly it
doesn't show back have you ever listed
kate lifted cases of cokes and water and
yeah no it does hurt your back it's not
and besides that that means he's been on
get rich quick scam tick-tock crap
that's exactly where you get that
because nobody else is teaching you to
buy vending machines as an investment
except idiots on tick-tock it's coming
back around all the old trends well all
the old trends in a new way
i mean we just found out a high-tech way
to do stupid now that's all it is all
right jancey is with us jency's in
orlando hi jensey welcome to the ramsey
show
hey how are you doing this afternoon
better than we deserve what's up great
great okay i have a question i just did
the
uh five minute coverage checkup for the
confidence in your coverage
and you have a question there that says
do you have life insurance
yes i have life insurance but when you
ask cash value or term
mine is i have a level term life policy
you're the right kind
do i keep that yes
level term because it does have a cash
value
it's not level term if it has a cash
value
term insurance does not have a cash
value
that's what they're calling it level
term life insurance
and it has a cash value
uh horace mann okay no you don't keep it
it's crap
don't keep it okay in 20 years i can
turn around and give them the cash value
back no no no no no no no no this is
horrible it's horrible horrible horrible
investment yeah it's too expensive way
too expensive how much coverage have you
got
it's a hundred thousand and i pay 84 a
month i bet you do how old are
you 51. okay
jump on zanderinsurance.com
and get a quote on real
20-year level term insurance it has no
cash value build up all it the only way
it pays is if you die and you're going
to find it to be less than half of what
you're paying now
and if you'll take the money that you
save and invest it you'll have a lot
more than all horus will give you later
okay that's what i wanted to know okay
so um thank you for taking that checkup
that's cool i'm glad it activated it's
helpful perfect
yeah yeah that is it is good it's
interesting but i've been wondering
about this policy for a while what your
thoughts would be on it now they're an
old old old antique uh whole life
company
right and at the end of the 20 years the
the uh payout dropped yeah your grandpa
probably bought that all the money
that's an old company that's an old
school
backwoods oh nasty stuff
sounds like she got it was marketed to
her as level term but it really was just
whole life
they just lied on the cover of it or
something i don't know because it's not
term
term insurance is for a term and has no
cash free value build up that is the
actual definition so
even if you name it a duck it's still
not a duck
it's still a hog so confusing horse the
hog yeah but there you go so it's been
around for a long time um the idea with
cash value is that you have the cash
value while you're alive isn't that
great but you don't get both so you
don't get the face of the policy and the
cash value right
so it's a terrible so when you die after
you paid extra to build up the savings
they pay only the face
amount and they don't pay the cash value
they keep the money you paid extra to
build up a savings account that when you
die they keep
it's a really horrible if that was part
of the sales pitch no one would buy if
cash value insurance is the payday
lender of the middle class it's a
complete screw job
it's nasty bad horrible product so if
you've got it get term life in place and
then cancel the whole time never cancel
a policy till you have the new one in
place chancy
don't cancel it until you get the new
one in place but get get on the phone
get on the line with xander and they'll
get you a quick term policy and you're
going to be blown away at how much
you've been overpaying
this is the ramsay show
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
[Music]
still on baby step number one huh
how'd you guess
with health care costs rising learn how
christian healthcare ministries can help
you make the most out of your budget
visit
chministries.org budget don't worry
it's worth it
[Music]
so
[Music]
in the lobby of ramsey solutions on the
debt-free stage chris and kim are with
us hey guys how are you great dave how
are you better than i deserve welcome
where do you guys live we live in exonia
wisconsin which is exactly in the middle
between milwaukee and madison cool
welcome to nashville thank you good to
have you guys and how much debt have you
paid off gosh we paid off 101
440 and 16 cents perfect how long did
that take it took us two years and two
weeks all right
like it and your range of income during
that two years that's about 135 to 150
and back down to about 125. cool what do
y'all do for a living well during my
debt-free journey uh i was a
correctional officer for a large
sheriff's department
and i was a nurse case manager ah okay
and you said you were what are you doing
now well right now i'm going back to
work that matters to me and that i'm
passionate about so now i'm back into
landscaping which i've i've always
really loved and i'm gonna see where
that takes me very cool good for you fun
what kind of debt was the 101 uh
unfortunately it was everything dave
house and everything no it was
everything oh every kind of debt oh
we're super normal sorry oh all right
uh credit cards about uh 25 000 we had
two auto loans for about twenty four
thousand
a 401 k loan at about nineteen thousand
a consolidation loan at about fourteen
thousand
student loans at about ten thousand and
then shortly after we started our debt
free journey came at a series of medical
events that led us to about 6 100 of
medical debt oh my goodness you
collected them all yes you got i mean
you had the whole collection man i mean
wow
how long y'all been married uh it was 15
years last week yeah last week so what
happened at two year ago mark that was
the wake up call and what changed
everything gosh um even before our
debt-free journey uh we used we're
originally from massachusetts so we
moved to wisconsin about 2012
and then after owning a house for that
time in massachusetts we had when we
moved
uh we went to renting for four years and
then at about 2016 we were starting to
get a little itchy
our littles were running around and we
didn't have the space in the apartment
complex so we slowly started the process
of buying a house now it wasn't the
right way to buy a house but certainly
we
started the process so we paid down some
debt but we weren't 100 debt free um
so then
we figured out that it might be a good
idea to maybe take a loan against kim's
401k
which was a really bad idea hindsight
being 2020 for sure but we took out a
loan for roughly 40 000. some of the
proceeds went towards the down payment
of the house and the rest went two
things that people always do when they
buy a house they buy brand new furniture
they do new landscaping they do all the
things
so you fast forward a year later
uh unfortunately the debt that we had
paid off we had racked back up
um
which really scared us quite quite
frankly it scared me as well we didn't
adjust our budget for doubling our
mortgage based on what our rent was
before so
we're still living the same way yet our
expenses were a lot more
um
so then kim thought it might be a good
idea maybe if we do a consolidation loan
and i was a little weary in the
beginning gotta move it yeah you guys
just did everything we did it was
horrible you did everything what was the
wake up call two years ago what happened
so
i think it you know it was funny that
that fall leading up to 2020 i had kind
of shut down i was working overtime a
lot over time in law enforcement and um
i was throwing a a ton of money at our
dad at our credit cards but then the
next month everything was racked back up
and then some so i had kind of given up
and i wasn't man enough to have a strong
conversation with my wife and let her
know that i was scared but
um
you know
what we finally saw was you know kim kim
bought this book the complete guide to
money by dave ramsey i'm like oh what's
this she's like oh it's book whatever
um
she she had asked me at one point hey
can you
help me figure out how to do this
podcast thing i want to listen to the
dave ramsey podcast is this a trick kim
i'm just not very uh electronic exactly
this was like hey help me listen to this
thing the trick comes in pretty soon
when i
just kind of keep playing it audibly uh
leaning better at night
yep so um
since i had
figured out a way to get her to listen
to the podcast or or
at least
no it wasn't me but to get them to work
to get it to get her to figure it out um
it was funny i actually listened to it
one day and uh i remember the story of i
think was a pharmacist down in south
florida that called and said that he was
thrilled that he made two hundred
thousand dollars a year and he had paid
off ten thousand dollars at debt in one
year and i think you shredded them
immediately
you sound like you needed it yeah yeah
for sure and uh listening to that i was
like man this guy's pretty cool i like
this
and um of course as you listen to the
podcast you start hearing that well i'm
on baby step two in baby step three b
and i'm like well what are these baby
steps what's this all about
um so i immediately took the book from
the bed stand or the nightstand and i
read it in one night and i was like man
we gotta do this this just makes a lot
of sense
kim you made it his idea you're a genius
you're a genius kim thank you dave i
needed that today wow so you you said
i'm done with the shortcuts and the life
hacks so we can borrow from the 401k and
consolidate over here and you realize we
just got to get out of this thing my
plan was not working you know moving the
money moving the debt just didn't seem
to get us any further ahead and i didn't
know how to tackle it and this this plan
helped us to figure out how to how to
knock it out what do you tell people the
key to getting out of debt is you pay
off a hundred and one thousand in two
years in two weeks it's so impressive
thank you
um
man i mean all the same things that
everyone talks about of course the
budget being on the same page with your
spouse
um
for me uh you know
i think on a simple level if if you've
been married or you have a spouse or you
have someone you're in a serious
relationship with
don't be scared to have a hard
conversation with your spouse
because
if i was you know strong enough to have
that conversation years before we'd be
in a different position now
um and also i i think
you just you got to get pissed off for
greatness
that's a good quote you just have to you
just have to get out of work
you know all of the all of the mornings
getting up early at 1 o'clock in the
morning to go work at the jail
you know staying late till 11 o'clock at
night you know kim
kim doing instacart that we did together
as well as you know share with that
whatever it takes she did a dairy farm
for a couple weeks you brought the
kiddos with you what are their names and
ages let's get them in yeah so we have
lily
she's 13 and we have gage is 12. all
right very cool we got a copy of baby
steps millionaires for you that's the
next chapter in your story for sure
and a copy of total money makeover for
you to give away and maybe does what the
complete guide to money guy did for you
guys that'd be awesome and also got a
one-year subscription to financial peace
university if you've not been through it
go through it if you have been through
it give it to somebody we've given you
some things to give away and pay it
forward with here as well thank you so
much so proud of y'all thanks for your
heroes man you did it so proud so very
very cool i worked your tail end off and
busted through in a complete change it's
just uh man when the when the student is
ready the teacher will appear
mysteriously on a podcast while your
wife tries to get you to show you how it
works i like this this is so good tech
support ladies that's the hackathon
that's it
tech support i need some help here with
this would you help me with this yeah i
don't know how to work it wink wink all
right chris kim lilly gage madison
wisconsin area milwaukee wisconsin area
101
000 paid off in two years in two weeks
making 135 to 150 count it down let's
hear a dead free scream
three
two
one we're dead
[Applause]
[Music]
just like that and that's why you travel
all the way across the country to have
that feeling worth it the braveheart
scream yeah baby
get pissed off for greatness america
what are you waiting for pissed off for
greatness a that's like a campaign
slogan yeah that would work that might
be that might get you elected if you
have a run dave that could be it i'm not
running i'm running from running but
that's not happening yeah we like it
that way i i don't want to take a bigger
pay cut my life's good
oh my gosh you guys are incredible well
done gang well done
heroes in the house
this is the ramsay show
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
well there's so much crazy going on out
there people are looking for direction
on how to handle their finances
but they're also struggling to see if
it's even possible to build wealth at
our building wealth live event we'll
walk you through all the crazy that's
going on and teach you how to really
build wealth in this situation
just like we always do and these are the
only principles that work in prosperous
times and they work in hard times and no
matter where you are with your money
today you can get on a path to building
wealth the building wealth live tour has
already made a couple of sold out stops
in las vegas and orlando wrapping up our
spring portion of the tour it's been
great we're just getting started though
got quite a few in four more in the fall
phoenix is september the 13th sacramento
november the 1st minneapolis november
the 10th san antonio november the 15th
rachel cruz george campbell ken coleman
dr john deloney and me we will all be
there we look forward to signing your
books taking pictures with you answering
questions we're going to do all kinds of
stuff it's going to be an incredible
event at each of those cities on those
dates by the way those are all 85 to 95
sold out so if you want a ticket don't
wait much longer event passes for these
things start as low as 25 and you can
get a four pack as low as 60 so take a
bunch of friends with you it's going to
be amazing ramsay solutions.com
events phoenix sacramento minneapolis
san antonio all this fall gonna be fun
george i love it we've had a great time
so far and the people have been amazing
that's been my favorite part just seeing
people again absolutely
derek is in winston-salem hi derek
welcome to the ramsey show
hey how you doing better than we deserve
sir what's up
hey y'all well i was hoping you'd ask me
how i'm doing
how are you
i'm better than i deserve there we go
okay good how can we help
so my question is um my wife and i just
paid off all consumer debt outside of
the mortgage um
we're sort of looking on guidance
how intensely we should put towards the
emergency fund well we've been putting
about a thousand dollars a week towards
debt
until we got debt free and now
just sort of looking for the intensity
we need we need to find
as intense as you've been getting out of
debt until you get the emergency fund
done baby steps one through three you do
like your hair is on fire scorched earth
nothing is going on until you get that
emergency fund in place and have no
doubt because that is the baseline for
not being broke anymore then you can
start to invest and we move from gazelle
intensity to in baby steps four through
seven intentionality
so what's the uh fully funded emergency
fund for you
what number
so
well we haven't really done the numbers
but i'd say it close to forty thousand
at least that's your expenses
for three to six months
that feels really high i would want
no i don't know i don't care what you
want your emergency fund should be three
to six months of expenses
and forty thousand it's not that that's
not forty thousand what's your household
income
uh last year 136.
okay so what's it take to operate your
house if you don't have any debt per
month
probably less than two thousand
you're not doing a budget are you
yes sir written every week
then you should tell me how if you do a
budget how much it takes to operate your
house
you should know that you guessed
yeah well we need to we need to tighten
that up well we'll see we
our house payment's 900 and then we have
no no sewer we've got a septic tank and
well so no expenses there and then
so rough number you'd say i'm 30 grand
i'm calling it three grand three grand
six months that's 18 grand so yeah you
need uh between 10 and 20 000 as your
emergency fund and you said you're
putting away a thousand a week and so
that tells me in 18 weeks you got a
fully funded emergency for 10 weeks you
know somewhere in there yeah you're
gonna be fine with ten or fifteen
thousand dollars is your emergency fund
then you slow down
and go to intentionality from
intensity at that point
but that that's exactly how you do it so
maybe he's nervous on the radio maybe he
really has a budget but i believe him
but when you can't tell me your numbers
that tells me you don't know your
numbers so something's up or maybe you
just got flat-footed a little scary here
on the air it's hard to be honest it's
hard to get on the air unless you do it
every day so that's true we'll give him
the benefit of the doubt open phones at
triple eight eight two five five two two
five george campbell ramsey personality
is my co-host today steve is in
wisconsin hi steve welcome to the ramsay
show
hello sir
um
don't yell at me first off i've done
some stupid things
took out a whole life policy about 20
years ago
um at my age that's the dumbest thing
you ever did you're brilliant
i've done a lot of things than that
brother
yeah i know you're not big on whole life
no i wouldn't i mean i wouldn't tell you
to keep it but um no
well here's the issue i'm 60 years old
we got about 800
000 in our 401ks and stuff
75 000 left on the house otherwise we're
debt free way to go um
not sure
with this whole life if i need it
anymore can i just get rid of life
insurance and not have it anymore or
should i
turn it and uh get rid of it and get a
term
how old are you
60. how old your wife
um i'm not gonna tell you she's gonna
shoot me
unless she's 59. okay all right so
if uh what what does she if you died
what would it take her to live a year in
income how much income would she need to
live on
reasonably reasonably not beans and rice
but have a good life have a good life
and be glad you're gone how much would
it take
well we don't we only i only make fifty
thousand a year okay so fifty thousand a
year she'd live on that comfortably
well that's before taxes so yeah she'd
be able to make you know i think yeah
but if she got 50 000 a year and had to
pay taxes on the 50 or 60 she'd be okay
right
yeah i would think so okay if 800 000
produces 10
rate of return in mutual funds that's 80
000
i think she's okay
if you've got it do you have the 800 000
invested in mutual funds
uh yeah two different different things
before when my 401k and uh
other mutual funds and stuff like that
so sit down with one of our smart
investor pros and and have her
understand with you
how you would invest the how she would
invest the 800 000 and make a living off
of that without touching the 800 000 if
you die
once she understands that you'll
understand that you need to pay off the
house tomorrow and you don't need any
life insurance
okay how much cash value is in this
policy
it's about 350 that one's 250.
the cash value is 350 000. oh i'm sorry
if i uh if i die let's do 50 there's
only like 15 000. okay so the face is
350 the cash value is 15. got it yeah
that'll help the house
well that'll get us closer than paying
off the house yes yeah you're only both
75 you get 50 when you cancel this
stupid policy
and so without any house payments she
can make it off of the income that 800
000 produces you're following me here
but sit down with your smart investor
pro your financial advisor and
understand how that works and let her
understand how that works so she has
peace about this and then cancel that
policy and pay off your house
but you need to understand why you're
doing that not just because dave ramsey
said to do it yeah and let's see in the
math and see it on paper you go
oh okay yeah if this happens this is
what's going to keep me afloat and
that's called being self-insured and
that's what we tell people once the term
policies what we
obviously recommend once that's out and
it's over after 15 20 years you should
be self-insured if you're following our
plan because you have a paid for house
got plenty of money in the bank you've
been investing that's exactly where he
is yeah he became self-insured he got
800 000 in mutual funds and he's gotta
paid for a house and the kids are grown
and gone you're self-insured you have no
i mean because six uh what eight percent
on
eight hundred thousand sixty-four
thousand still you're gonna be okay
and so she's gonna be just fine and you
get rid of that mortgage payment plus
you get rid of the whole life premiums
now we're looking even better yeah i'm
i've been trying to get rid of the life
insurance for years because i i want to
be worth more alive than dead because
it's good for my health for sharon
i thought
i don't want her often me in my sleep so
sharon just wants you to have it first
for her own personal piece s-w-i sharon
wants it
anything that falls in that bucket
sharon gets it wow
it's just it's a horrible thing
but 40 years we've been married so it's
working it's worth it swi is always
worth it this is the ramsey show
[Music]
do you love a good dave rant want to see
the latest ramsay show videos going
viral check out your favorite moments
from the ramsay show on youtube go watch
and subscribe to the ramsay show channel
on youtube
[Music]
this is the ramsay show
[Music]
you can be intentional about your
character you can have money and a
career you are the hero in your story
live from the headquarters of ramsey
solutions it's the ramsey show where
debt is dumb cash is king and the paid
off home mortgage has taken the place of
the bmw as the status symbol of choice
we help people build wealth do work that
they really love and create actual
amazing relationships open phones here
at
825-5225 george campbell ramsey
personality host of the entree
leadership podcast is my co-host today
as we answer your questions about your
life and your money emerson is in
chicago to start off this hour hi
emerson how are you
hey i'm doing great dave uh thanks for
taking my call sure what's up
so uh my wife and i were on baby steps
four five and six we are a blended
family with
five beautiful children the oldest
getting ready to go into her senior year
of high school
she just got her cna
and wishes to continue
the nursing path
and get her rn
here in
after her senior year my question is
kind of two-part
there's a local community college here
that offers has a great rn program
my wife and i have saved enough money to
send our
daughter through that
with cash debt-free
however she has
recently gone on
several college visits to
expensive universities
and that would require her to go into a
significant amount of debt
so my i guess my question is how can i
create more buy-in for her to try and
lead her down the
um debt-free path
and if we are unable to do so how would
you recommend we spend the money we
saved for her being that we intended to
keep her out of debt and not use it to
get her out of debt
so what has a conversation been like
when you say hey we've saved up enough
money for you to go to this school and
she says no i want to go to this
expensive school and you what's your
next question how are you going to pay
for it
yeah yeah absolutely how are you going
to pay for it and you know the student
loan thing uh comes up all the time i
feel like we've kind of thrown our a
a lot of data we've used up all our dave
ramsey uh weaponry to kind of certainly
that's not working just saying that well
dave said it's got to be on her terms
and she's got to understand the
implications of the weight of student
loans which she has no clue about right
now has she been working you said as a
cna uh yeah
uh yeah well so she she just got her cna
a couple weeks ago um at the end when
she graduated uh so
you're a really nice man um because i
wouldn't have let my daughter go on
tours of colleges
she lives in my house
you can't you can't go test drive
bentley's if you can't afford a bentley
there's no reason to go on the lot no
reason to go on the lot
except get pissed off that you can't get
a bentley that's all that happens
and so yeah she certainly has you said
blended family is this your stepdaughter
no it's it's my daughter however she's
she lives mostly with her mother oh
so that's that's part of the uh the
battle here okay so her mother and you
you're not talking about your current
wife and you have saved up enough money
your ex and you
so so my current wife and i have saved
up the money oh your ex is not putting
any money in the equation
correct and yet she's stirring up the
pot
you got it
found the problem
not the kid
okay
i mean you you can't you can tell it's
not about dave ramsey okay here's an
idea what about this do you have any
good friends that are rns that are like
40 years old or 50 years old
yes
have one of them take her to dinner and
knock her on the head
okay
and go i'm an rn and the dumbest thing
you could ever do is go pay money in
student loan debt for the college
experience when you can go get an rn for
free because your dad will pay for it
that's dumber than a rock have them tell
her that
okay she'll listen to a nurse right
that's what she wants to be because
here's the point she is not going into
debt to become an rn she's going into
debt to attend a freaking college that
she wants to go to she can be an rn
without debt we've established that so
really all she's borrowing money for is
beer pong
that's right that is correct this is
bullcrap i mean they got a good call
they got a good football team which you
don't play on darling
okay
i mean
you can attend the game over there for a
lot cheaper than you can attend the
college over there we talk about this in
the bard future documentary which i
would recommend you sit down and watch
with her and have a conversation about
it afterwards 88 minutes it will
definitely change the way she sees the
entire college i'll give you a free list
we'll give you a free link to watch
borrowed future together and we'll send
you a copy of debt-free degree
uh but here's what you're gonna have to
do is there any chance you get to talk
to your ex in a reasonable tone and she
actually catches on to the idea that
this has to stop and she needs to quit
this
no i've tried that
i i sent her a long text message and uh
with used uh soft gloves so to speak and
uh kind of just a little bit of where
she's coming from i you know she she she
thinks you know that uh because some
places offer free parking and free
laundry
that
that uh that's worth um
going into that going into and so i miss
the part where it's free
exactly yeah that's dumber than a rock
oh my god wow okay yeah yeah well i
don't know if you're going to
counterbalance your ex-wife's stupidity
it's going to be difficult but i think
if you get a good rn to take your
daughter to dinner and knock her on the
noggin and tell her that she does not
need to do this it's a dumb idea go be
an rn and then you can have some
experiences
and you because you'll be making a lot
of money and you don't have to go to co
that other college to do that number one
number two we'll give you a link to uh
hang on also pick up we'll give you a
link to borrowed future watch that with
your daughter the next time she's there
lock her in the room with you don't say
anything let her talk when the movie's
over believe me george and i and the
gang in borrowed future will do our jobs
it is uh it will scare the bejesus out
of you on student loan debt when you
watch this thing it isn't the student
loan program is an epic
failure
um but here's the thing oh you asked me
one other question i didn't answer
if you don't do what i want you to do
that i think is wise and good for you
because i love you i will give you no
money i will not fund your stupidity
partially
i will not participate financially in
your crazy butt decisions
this is dave talking to his kids
this is exactly what it sounded like at
our house
no
is a complete sentence
no
it's dumb and i'm not going to
participate in my daughter who i love
being dumb and crazy and i'm not going
to fund it now you're going to be nicer
than that because you are a nice guy i'm
just that dad
so hang on allston will pick up we'll
get you the book
and the documentary and
yeah you've got done riled them up man
the landscaping the football team the
water slide the ex-wife the lazy river
the whole thing it's got the whole story
here this is the ramsey show
[Music]
hmm
[Music]
if you're looking for ways to update
your home without blowing the budget
i've got it for years i've been telling
you about our friends at blinds.com
blinds.com makes it simple to shop top
quality blinds shades and interior
shutters from home with easy online
ordering and free
shipping with blinds.com there's no need
to renovate your entire home just change
out what's on your windows with upscale
choices like faux wood blinds cellular
and roller shades or even outdoor shades
plus blinds.com guarantees the perfect
fit whether you do it yourself or you
have them measure and install everything
for you shop their latest looks and see
how much you can save at blinds.com
today the easy and affordable way to
make your home more beautiful is
blinds.com
[Music]
real estate market's slowing down but
still one of the best times to sell a
house
probably the best time in the next five
years right now
real estate market's slowing down but it
is not going down in price and this is
the best time to buy a house it's a very
unusual time that it's the best time to
sell the best time to buy usually it's
one or the other right now at this
moment it may not be in six months but
at this moment it is the best time to do
both right now you do need a pro in your
corner someone who actually knows what
they're doing someone who sells a lot of
houses
uh if you're gonna if if i assigned you
if you work for me and i signed you the
task of marketing a 500 000
project and you hired a marketing
consultant who had done it one time
i would fire you for stupidity
note to self really that i mean
seriously if you're going to hire a
marketing consultant to do a 500 000
project and they've only ever done it
one time they're not a consultant
they're just unemployed
okay
and that's what a real estate agent is
they're a consultant on how to do a
transaction the proper way to price a
transaction and carry you through a very
complicated project called the sale of
your largest asset you do not want your
uncle charlie who got his license three
weeks ago to sell it for you that's dumb
or your aunt who has a friend joyce who
just got in the business
and joyce really would like to lease
your house well i bet joyce would like
to list your house joyce's don't use her
no that's dumb you get a professional
who sells 100 houses a year 50 hours a
year 300 houses a year to do your house
deal
this is this is smart you know and
that's why we have endorsed local
providers that we endorse go to
ramseysolutions.com they're high octane
we don't put our name we don't tell you
to go to so and so endorsed ramsey
trusted if they've done two transactions
last year
that they're not qualified
okay and let me tell you that's most
real estate agents
most of them
90 i'm making this up but 95 of the
transactions are done by about six or
eight percent of the agents in the
market the rest of them got their
license thought it'd be fun and didn't
work much
that's what it amounts to sorry for your
newbies but that's how it works in the
business i've had my license since 1978
i know this business ramsey solutions
dot com slash agent find an agent that
we recommend in your area our question
of the day
is from blinds.com find out for yourself
why they are the number one online
retailer of custom window coverings with
free samples free shipping and new
promos they run every month you'll save
even more use the promo code ramsey to
get the best possible deal today's
question comes from erica in houston my
boyfriend and i have been together for
five years and have a three-year-old son
we're both 24 years old we rent a house
from his parents
last year he earned over a hundred and
ten thousand dollars
he has twelve months of expenses saved
in addition to his ten thousand dollar
emergency fund along with two other
accounts that are well over ten thousand
dollars the only debt we have is twenty
five thousand on his car
i'm a full-time college student work
part-time and i'm home four days a week
with our son so we don't have child care
expenses we have a great relationship he
can clearly afford an engagement ring
but he still uses our finances as a
reason why we aren't engaged yet is this
a legit concern
if not what do you think the holdup is
well erica um
i don't know that he wants to marry you
based on his actions and his behavior he
has plenty of money
he has 12 months of expenses sitting
there in a savings account so the fact
that he's saying he can't afford an
engagement ring is an excuse
there's something else going on here
he's scared a commitment um even though
he had a child with you and lives with
you
so there's a deeper relationship issue
here this is not a financial issue
wow i'm sorry honey
um
well
it's a problem
yeah i think that you probably uh need
to sit down with a good
counselor
both of you um and decide if this
relationship's going to go forward i
hate that it might not because there's a
five-year-old involved
because y'all got things out of order
here
and when you get things out of order
people's lives get messed up
and y'all decide to have babies before
you got married and that's getting
things out of order sorry but it messes
things up
and it makes your life difficult and it
hurts
so i sure hope that a good coach or a
good counselor a good therapist can walk
you walk him through his immaturity
because i have a feeling you're sleeping
with a little boy
and i'm not talking about your son
um i don't think you got a man here
he makes a little bit of money
but uh he's not acting very manly
he's acting like a scared little boy
and if i was your dad i'd be scared for
you right now and i am scared for you
i sure hope i'm wrong i hope you can get
him to the table
but if uh if i wake up in your shoes i'm
going to begin a process a gentle but
steady process
of
bringing this to an end or bringing him
to the altar
he gets a choice
and um i'm not gonna stay you get a
painter get off the ladder here buddy
that's a deal
uh you don't get to keep
keep this arrangement it's not good for
you it's not good for the baby it's not
uh it's an uns you're vulnerable you are
very vulnerable here
he could just stand up and walk out the
door
and you got nada
except a broken heart and you're a
single mom
and uh yeah he needs to uh
he needs to decide what he wants to do
and i would get some professional help
and helping him decide that and
hopefully we can bring him around i'm
sure he's not a bad guy
but he is immature and he's scared
george is right
and uh so it's time for him to grow up
he's a daddy
and he needs to act like it
and um it's a crisis we have in this
country right now absolutely thanks for
the thanks for the email i'm sorry for
you honey
this is the ramsey show open phones at
triple eight eight two five five two two
five george i gotta circle back to our
call before the break
um
as we have studied the student loan
crisis as an epic failure in america
um 1.7 trillion dollars in student loan
debt 45 million people carrying this
debt around their necks
um
when we do know that mathematically you
could choose a community college you can
choose an in-state school you can work
you can get scholarships and you can go
to school debt-free but people are
making choices like that very nice
gentleman's uh young daughter
being influenced by her mother his
ex-wife
to make a stupid decision and pay money
to get virtually the same education but
is but but go into debt to do it and
it's just a disaster
but rachel said something as we started
talking about this about three years ago
this stuck with me that we really do not
have
a student loan crisis we really have a
parenting crisis
so in his case he has a parenting crisis
because he cannot completely make the
decision because he's got his ex
in the mix messing up the decision
but um
and your parents who say well they're 18
they can do whatever they want if
they're 18
you need to have
more influence in their life they live
under your roof eat your food
drive your freaking car and are on your
cell phone plan
so they're not free agents
they are a dependent
which means they are dependent on your
butt
and they need to understand that so you
want to be mean to your kids or rough
with your kids or something like that i
never was that but no one was in no one
was confused about who was running the
asylum it wasn't the inmates
you know and so
if we have a parenting crisis a guy
called up and said well my son told me
he was going this expensive school see
that's we never had that conversation my
kids don't get to tell me stuff i told
them stuff
well you didn't listen to them well
that's why they're in counseling now but
they don't have any debt okay so it's
unbelievable
so the the parenting crisis moms and
dads is you need to start
today
if your kid is 1
11 or 18
you need to start today
so education at a trade school at a tech
school or a four-year degree but we're
not doing it with debt so we need to be
thinking about how we're going to do
that and you can start talking about
that at any age
this is we are a non-debt family
you will not be going into debt
we are going to figure out a way for you
to go to college without that we're
going to save up money and if you want
the money that's in my name that we
saved up for your use you will do it my
way baby because i have your best
interest at heart this is what's known
as a benevolent dictatorship
i'm benevolent but i own the freaking
money and i love you so much i'm not
going to participate in your craziness
start talking to your kids early about
this we've forgotten that college is for
education not for the landscaping and
the buildings
i don't know what's going on who knew
college was not for your pleasure and
entertainment
oh i thought that's what it was for give
me a break that was sarcasm in case you
people didn't know me
chaos
that's what it can feel like when your
business is growing so fast you've
outgrown your financial and accounting
software the faster you grow the more
likely you are to lose control of the
numbers and here's the reality if you
don't know your numbers you don't know
your business that's why we use netsuite
by oracle the number one cloud financial
system over 28 000 companies use
netsuite by oracle including ramsey
solutions because netsuite gives us a
single view of everything we need to
make daily decisions whether you're
making a few million to hundreds of
millions a year netsuite gives you the
visibility and control of the things you
need to grow like your financials
inventory hr planning budgeting and more
all in one dashboard go to netsuite.com
ramsey right now to get their free white
paper jumpstart your cfo career
[Music]
george campbell ramsey personality is my
co-host in the lobby of ramsey solutions
on the debt free stage brandon and katie
are with us hey guys how are you hi hey
dave welcome welcome good to have you
guys where do you all live
this is right up the road bowling green
kentucky all right home of the corvette
that's right very good i picked one up
up there one time oh good for you it was
actually at the museum two weeks for it
fell in oh yes that was scary
really that's a while back but yeah
welcome to nashville how much debt you
pay off 105 000 all right how long did
this take six and a half years wow okay
and your range of income during that
time about 62 to 78 000. cool and what
kind of debt was the 105 it was our
house
baby step seven
what's this house worth
uh today
uh 220 maybe all right very cool good
for y'all not a payment in the world
i love it i love it
so tell us about your journey how did
you decide to do this and get connected
to the ramsey stuff
so um it started back in 2012
katie's mom
actually introduced us to financial
peace university
um but we did it on cd
and so
we went through it and so we started
following the baby steps made a lot of
sense
uh we paid off car debt uh fortunately
we didn't have a lot of college debt i
had an rtc scholarship and
katie's family was very generous so we
were already on a you know a good path
but
uh still needed a lot of direction and
and that's where the baby steps really
helped
but um it wasn't till um 2020 we did the
actual financial peace university class
and that's when things got real
um
we just
i was calculating the numbers and i was
like we can pay this house off we can do
it kept running the numbers getting it
again and
um yeah just knocked it out cut up our
credit we were all in at that point
um and so that was that was a big big
change there
very good guys way to go you guys
fun fun so you started this six and a
half years ago but just two years ago
you kind of got amped up to go
just full throttle towards the finish
line here what was like the first four
years were you seeing some progress but
you went we could do we could do better
than this come on yeah i think so i mean
you know it that initial kind of
introduction to the baby steps and
everything was good for helping us to
pay off that smaller debt but then it
almost seemed not hopeless in its
entirety but just didn't seem as hopeful
when we bought our house which you know
we
put more than 20 down and everything and
did the did a 15-year mortgage it the
right way so to speak but um it just
didn't seem very feasible but then when
brandon sat down and we went through the
class and everything we're like oh it
just it just kind of clicked and we were
like oh i bet we can do this and it just
seemed more feasible and we just kept i
think it helped that he just
automatically just took out a little bit
of extra money each month
um and we
essentially i mean we obviously budgeted
around that and so we just
kept chipping away at it and we all do
for a living
i work up at western kentucky university
i'm a federal employee but i work in the
army rotc department and so i help
high school college students if they
want to become an army officer and help
them with scholarships enrollment that's
very cool yeah and i homeschool our
children and she's got the harder job
yeah
very good good for you guys that's fun
okay so uh what the pandemic is around
the time you kicked it in too so that
kind of gave you a little wake-up call
you're like oh we need to get this done
that's right yeah we started the class
yeah january 2020 so right and we
finished the last one and as the
pandemic's starting and so everything
was shut uh credit cards were done
because that was always a budget buster
um yeah we could pay them off every
month um but
at the end of the month i'm like all
right we got some money left over and
then it'd be like oh now we got to pay
off the credit card bill so that was
like that was freeing just getting rid
of that
um and then yeah anything extra we were
just tossing at the house
and yeah i just watched kept going
through the numbers even though they
didn't change i'm just watching it and
like we can do this we can do this
good for you guys way to go y'all proud
of you what do you tell people the key
to getting out of debt is now that
you've done it
i mean i think for me it was um just
being content and a lot of it and just
any time well not any every time but
sometimes when we would see people like
you know they brought they bought a
house or they you know before we bought
our home or they bought a car and our
mentality was there's two ways to go
about it you either paid cash for it or
you're in debt we obviously had no
interest in being in debt and if they
paid cash for it that's wonderful and
good for them and so that just kind of
helped our mentality i think um just you
know
continuing on with it for sure if you're
not curb all the comparisons yes exactly
wow that's powerful
good for you guys well done well done
well we've got a copy of baby steps
millionaires for you that's the next
chapter in your story you're definitely
going to be there a number one best
seller and we'll also give you another
number one bestseller the total money
makeover you can give that away to
somebody and get them started and we'll
give you a one-year subscription to
ramsey plus to financial peace
university which is good for you guys on
dvd but you can give this to somebody
and let them get started on their
journey you brought the kiddos with you
let's bring them up what are their names
and ages um joseph is about to turn
seven and then juniper is three and a
half all right
beautiful cute cute cute good stuff
all right brandon and katie joseph and
jennifer
105 000 paid off in six and a half years
house and everything
looking at weird people
making 62 to 78 count it down let's hear
a debt free scream
three
[Music]
that is how it's done ladies and
gentlemen joseph is jumping for joy on
the debt-free stage
we love to see it beautiful beautiful
well done well done those kids don't
even know what just happened gotta love
it gotta love it nicole is with us in
detroit hi nicole welcome to the ramsey
show
hi dave i appreciate you for taking my
call sure what's up um i'm
going calling today because we bought a
new home two years ago and we are using
our old home as an income property
um we don't owe anything on either of
our houses
and we are considering kind of taking
advantage of the market
and selling the rental property
wondering your thoughts on that our only
hold up is we just don't know what to do
with the games
we are
we've lost some money over the course of
the last six months with the stock
market being so volatile and it's got us
a little nervous to lost anything if you
didn't sell it did you sell it
no we didn't sell it okay it's just your
value is down but you haven't lost any
money i haven't lost any money because i
didn't sell it
you're right you're right
i've got to flip my thinking on that
um but so what are your thoughts on
on selling the house why would you sell
it
well
we would like to pay off our
debt that we have i thought you had no
debt and
well we don't we don't have house debt
but we have a check and we have a fifth
wheel that we have loans on
oh crap
so what do you owe on that junk
um we have 90 or 88 000 in the truck
and you want to keep it yo yo 88 000 on
the fifth wheel
no on both oh
god you could have stayed at the four
seasons a lot
okay
but we enjoy it oh it's more than
glamping it's yeah what's your income
what's your household income
my husband works he is at 88 000 i'm on
disability and
it's a total of 107 000.
you're not going to like me
okay give it to me you should not invest
in 88 000 or dollars worth of things
that go down in value when you only make
a hundred thousand
okay
so you're selling the wrong thing
selling the wrong thing so sell the junk
i'd sell the fifth wheel before i sell
around a truck and i'd keep the house
that goes up in value instead of having
a camper sit in the backyard rotting
while you sleep in it six nights a year
that's some nice camp
you can afford that if you make 300
grand a year but you cannot afford that
if you make 100 grand a year
it's too much loss because that camper
is gonna be worth nothing in six years
nothing nada when something goes down in
value those puppies
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
george campbell ramsey personality is my
co-host today open phones a triple eight
eight two five five
two two five tristan is with us tristan
is in canton ohio hi tristan welcome to
the ramsay show
hey mr ramsay how are you better than i
deserve sir how can george and i help
so i got a bit of a mouthful for you um
i'm 22 years old i've about my
girlfriend and i've been dating for
around six years we're only boyfriend
girlfriend right now we live in my mom's
house and it's currently like a nice
situation you know nothing that's
happening my question is is that with
listening to your show for the past
month or so we kind of realized how bad
we are with our finances and our debt
about two years ago um i bought a
motorcycle and i currently around 22
thousand dollars on it and i also bought
a truck about four years ago and i owe
around eight thousand dollars on me and
my girlfriend we want to you know get
engaged and buy a house and say or save
up for a house here soon my question is
that should i sell a motorcycle um and
break even on it and then just work on
paying off my truck or i've already
budgeted out monthly and i figured out
that i could pay off all 30 grand within
10 months but that's all i'm focusing
i'm not focusing on saving anything or
nothing
okay what do you make
currently i have true jobs and i make
around 60 to 70 000.
okay good for you you're working hard
i am thank you
okay so i i want to back up i got
confused on the details a little bit
okay so you are living with your
girlfriend
at your parents house
uh yes sir
okay
and y'all aren't married why
um because we
we haven't gone that far well we want to
it's um i'm buying a ring and we're
going to propose i've already got the
blessing from her dad and everything um
she heard that she was living with her
parents and they left the state and she
wanted to stay here with me and she
didn't want to go get an apartment so i
finished my basement and she's living in
my basement
so you don't live in the same room
no sir okay i'm so okay i just i'm the
clarity on this is helpful thank you um
i'm sorry okay um
wow how much money do you have in the
bank
uh
right now i have around
three grand
okay is she working
uh she works two part-time jobs and i
would say probably annually she can
bring in 15 20.
is she in school
uh no sure how much do you stay at home
mom uh she's 22. she's a stay-at-home
mom you have a kid no she no she wants
to be she doesn't want to go to college
or anything right now she's making money
on the side
oh actually okay
okay well if i'm in your shoes i'm
selling the motorcycle i'm getting a
ring i'm getting married and moving
forward with our life because i think
she's more important than the motorcycle
would you agree i would agree oh yeah
you didn't have a choice on that answer
brother i was trying to completely
trapped you yeah you were dead
here's the thing here's the thing she
actually i'm the one who's wanting to
sell the motorcycle
she
does not want me to sell it yeah that's
sweet that's sweet and all but it's dumb
you need you need to sell a motorcycle
yeah um okay
so what's what's your household income
for the year
67 60 70 years a thousand this feels
like a lot of motorcycle and being 60
70. and your your truck is how much is
your truck worth uh i owe about well
it's worth around 15 by around eight on
it okay good good yeah let's get rid of
the motorcycle wait a minute you have a
you you have a 22 000 motorcycle
yes sir
oh we're definitely selling the
motorcycle yeah
okay what's the payment on that
uh 440 a month yeah
that's a sweet bike what is it
uh it's a 2020 harley-davidson fat boy
30-year anniversary jeez man that's a
beast
i'm sorry i'm so sorry i'm sorry i was a
smart aleck but you still got to sell it
oh my gosh oh that's a wonderful bike
but yeah it's completely out of school
here it's the it's the thing that sticks
out in your whole story is the dumbest
thing in the whole story the rest of the
stories that's what i tell everyone yeah
the rest of your story is a pretty good
story i mean you got a good situation
going on you're being very moral and
very right uh you ask her dad for his
blessing he gave it which means you're a
good guy
um man i'm just i think there's a whole
lot good going on with you yeah the
motorcycle's just the dumbest thing in
the picture yeah get rid of it i love it
though it's awesome i'm sorry you'll get
you another bike though you'll get you
another bike i mean someday you'll get a
bike and you'll own the bike this time
and it won't on you
yeah just listen to your show we kind of
just realized how dumb we are
no you're not dumb i mean really overall
you've done a good job it's just that's
the one thing that's sticking out big
time
so then then you only got eight thousand
dollars in a couple months you're debt
free and you don't need to buy a house
you just go rent an apartment and you
guys get married
okay
i think she needs to find some some work
she enjoys doing yeah it's fine if one
day she wants to be developing a career
even if uh even if she does choose to
come and just be a full-time mom after
babies come and all that but if i were
you
i i would work diligently to
be
out of the car debt and out of your
mom's house and married by fall
okay
and i think you can do that
i think i can too okay
we believe in you yeah and of course the
motorcycle's gone and you started your
life i mean you know when i was 22
sharon and i were married we live in a
one-bedroom apartment we had two junky
little cars and we started off our life
and we were dumber than a rock we were a
lot dumber than you tristan i mean we
really were
um i mean if you looked at our finances
they were horrible
and you know and i just expanded that
horrible and made it you know with
millions and it was horrible and then i
went broke and lost everything because i
expanded my stupidity so tristan you
really got a good start yeah you really
it's a reversible decision it was a cool
thing to dig into your story though and
start to understand what all was going
on there because it at first it sounded
like it's one thing and then i got a
whole nother definitely a strange
situation not the norm you got to learn
a little bit about what's happening
there
good i like it jeremy's with us in grand
junction colorado hi jeremy how are you
pretty good how are you guys good how
can we help
um starting off on baby step six just
have a question about paying off early
good um can i potentially pay off
earlier by throwing the extra 500 in an
s p 500 fund no is it too risky to do
that it's not too risky but i just throw
it at the house
just throw it at the
house you're not going to gain enough to
screw with it just just beat this crap
out of that house what's left on the
mortgage
uh 200 000.
what's your income
income is 160. so how fast you think
you're gonna pay off 200
um i'm hoping 10 years
10 years
while throwing extra
um
yeah what's stopping you from throwing
50 grand a year at the extra on the
mortgage
um i guess i'm working on baby step
steps five and six
you don't know yeah but you'll throw a
few hundred bucks in college how much
how old are your
kids um oldest is 16. okay so you're
trying to play catch up on college
and that's draining down that's draining
a lot of your income right now
yeah okay because if you didn't if you
weren't throwing a chunk in there i mean
out of 160 you can certainly do more
than 20 000 a year right
yeah yeah so i think i don't think it's
gonna be ten but i think it might be six
i was guessing a four but i didn't have
your college number in my head when i
did that so
i was with george if you didn't have
college you could throw 50 a year at it
agreed
yeah and you'd be done in four but now
we got college and so we're not gonna
quite do that much so it's gonna take
instead of four it's probably gonna take
six or seven something like that but
yeah i don't think it needs to take ten
still but yeah you just throw money at
it dude just no money at it and it's
you know the people that we meet that
have become millionaires in our
millionaire study that we did over ten
thousand of them they had a paid for
house and they had a stocked full
retirement account and so it often
sounded like a paid for 500 600 000
house and million million one million
two in their 401k and roth iras
and it took them you know 15 to 17 years
to get there from the time they got to
where you are right now
and so
if you're not already a millionaire you
probably are going to be in about 10 or
12 from where you sit today
sweet can't wait yeah with the value of
your house and the value of your
investments agreed
yeah yeah and you will be a typical baby
steps millionaire at that point what i
would do too is jump onto the mortgage
payoff calculator at ramseysolutions.com
start playing with those numbers and
that gets you fired up you go what if i
could do an extra hundred bucks in that
and 200 bucks and 300 bucks and you
start to see that the amortization
schedule starts to dwindle and you start
paying less interest and more on the
principal
boom yeah once you introduce the concept
to your brain
that uh oh it's only 200 i mean that's
divided by ten is twenty thousand
divided by five is forty thousand by
four is fifty thousand just big math
right and all of a sudden you go hmm i
think i can do this
out of a hundred decisions most people
do it faster than they think they can
yeah absolutely absolutely once you once
you believe you can it's a big deal that
puts this hour of the ramsey show in the
books
[Music]
dave here you can find all of our shows
with the ramsey network app on your
smartphone it's the only place to listen
to the entire back catalog of episodes
download the ramsey network app in your
favorite app store today
[Music]
this is the ramsay show
[Music]
you can be intentional about your
character you can have money and a
career you are the hero in your story
[Music]
live
it's the ramsay show thank you for being
with us this is where debt is done cash
is king and the paid off home mortgage
has taken the place of the bmw as the
status symbol of choice we're
broadcasting from ramsey solutions this
is the show where we teach you how to
build wealth how to oh absolutely find
work that you love and actual
relationships yeah all of this works
together so you have a better life
george camel ramsey personalities my
co-host today open phones at triple
eight eight two five
five
two two five well george
the bear is in the house uh oh i keep
seeing the headlines the bear is here
the bear has arrived
market so scary scary bear
now bulls are scary too but for some
reason there's something about the bear
market dave it's got people riled up
what's going on there well
a bear market is like a recession it's a
thing that the media throws around is
like wow
tornado is coming get your bathtub put
on a helmet they got my click yeah
the bear marker's a bear market who's a
recession
oh
these are these are not good things well
we do have we have a tendency to
hyperbole and overreact and create
headlines and get people to watch our
new shows by doing these so what are my
chances of living just hit me straight
to talk about the bear market on fox a
little bit later oh funny so
um just you know i always get the phone
call when things are bad and so um
here we go again so here's a bear market
market's down 20 percent
that's definition that's it that's it i
thought the sky was falling nope chicken
little not happening
uh kind of disappointing i thought that
would be more but you know if you were
buying shoes and they were on sale 20
off you'd be excited i love i love a
good sale you know if you're buying a
car and it was 20 off that'd be a nice
thing but when your stocks are 20 off
and you get to buy them at a discount
um people don't think that way they
think that they've i've lost all my
money in the stock market
no you haven't lost anything unless you
sold it
i don't even know how much i've lost
because i haven't lost anything because
i haven't hold it
the only person that gets hurt on a
roller coaster are those that jump off
in the middle of the ride
ride the coaster baby
baby ride at the 401k balance you're
saying don't freak out i'm saying quit
staring at your 401k balance i even
looked at mine don't cash it out well
you're just yeah now here's the deal you
are not in this
for a two-week play
your 401k is not a two-week play it's
not a two-month play it's not a two-year
play your 401k is a 20 to or a 40-year
play
and so all you should care about is
where the market's going to be when you
get there that's all you should care
about
you don't have to care about what it is
in a given moment and the reason you
don't have to care about that is you're
thinking do you think the 20 off
honestly people if you're one of those
that's freaking out right now if you're
the one i'm making fun of because you're
melting down and you're in drama queen
mode if that's you
ask yourself do you really think that
the american economy is going to implode
now i mean stop your little feelings i'm
talking about use your intellect
breathe
do you really think
that all of these companies coca-cola
mcdonald's
home depot
apple
are gonna become worth zero
now come on
breathe breathe with me
they're not okay why are they down
because we have a screwed up economy
because of covid and joe biden screwing
with the gas pipelines
it's pretty simple
kovid's gonna go away and hopefully joe
will after a few more years
and it's gonna be okay right
quit screwing with stuff in the economy
and let the economy run and it runs just
fine
but covid messed up supply chain supply
demand prices went all wonky i mean my
god it's like the mississippi ran
backwards used cars went up in value
what a weird world we live in i mean
seriously this is a weird economy and
people who used to get ten dollars an
hour to put bread on the shelves now get
thirty dollars an hour to put bread on
the shelves and we wonder why the price
of bread went up because we all want a
universal wage for doing nothing and so
socialism is kicking in and you guys are
loving the benefits of it
and so this this is what's going on so
the bear market is simply the stock
market is following us into a recession
the stock peop the people are investors
are not feeling happy
they're feeling sad
and so they're not willing to pay as
much for a single stock as they were
thus the price of stock the stock market
is going down and it's down 20
which is a lot but it is not time to
panic
and if i were here's the thing
what is it buffett says he says uh i try
to be greedy when others are fearful are
fearful and fearful when others are
greedy great quote
and uh now you know i don't know if
buffett is actually greedy i don't look
at him as that type of person like
greedy but like more like yeah i want to
i want to be this is the time to buy
that's a contrarian mentality in other
words control upstream contrary to the
typical person out there the typical
investor okay so if the investors are
running away from the stock market and
it's going down that means it's on sale
when i was a kid and we went to kmart
which is now gone
uh that's how long ago this was but the
dinosaurs roamed the earth back then if
you went into kmart they had this little
box they would roll around that had a
little pole on it on top of it was a
blue light
like a like a like a
policeman's light right like uh sheriff
taylor is in town barney fife is here
right and so they would flip that little
light on and move it over next to
something and take whatever it was on
that rack and put it on sale it's called
a blue light special
and so you're on it's on sale and we
would all us rednecks would run to kmart
and go to the blue light specials and
get deals on whatever it was that we
didn't need at kmart and so but that's
all the stock market is it's on sale
it's a blue light special right now it's
down 20
you have the opportunity to buy so if
you think that the stock market if you
think the american economy companies
like home depot apple
and so on are going to be worth as a
group more 20 years from today then you
would be happy to buy more shares right
now while they're on sale would you not
that is logical
but not if you watch the news oh my god
you know it's just crazy out there right
and so sitting about to put the helmet
on the tornado is coming it's oh my god
like a bike helmet is going to help you
in a tornado you idiot right now
what about the group of people who are
actually trying to retire right now or
they're recently retired and they're
right you don't use all your money you
don't like okay today is my retirement
day i'm taking all of that money out
cash out eight hundred thousand dollars
and i'm gonna put it on my kitchen table
that is not what people do at retirement
okay what do you do at retirement if you
have eight hundred thousand dollars in
mutual funds do you take it all out no
what do you do
you take an income off of it
and you say i want that eight hundred
thousand to give me eighty thousand
dollars a year
and so you take eighty thousand dollars
a year off well it didn't make eighty
thousand so you use up a little your 800
and next year when you take out 80 and
it goes up 200 then you have to worry
about it because it all goes back
and so just set up your income out of it
you didn't lose your retirement
calm your butt
down
we are going into a little lightweight
recession two quarters in a row of the
economy not growing a recession is the
gross domestic product the adding up of
all goods and services in america two
quarters in a row shrunk that is a
recession it receded like my hairline
okay i wasn't gonna say it that's how it
works you weren't gonna say it but i did
[Music]
so
[Music]
george campbell ramsey personality is my
co-host today a lot of people would
rather spend their weekend doing yard
work than insurance i got a better idea
you get to see george as a ramsey
personality walk you through our new
five-day guide to insurance called
confidence in your coverage
makes learning about insurance quick and
practical you're going to laugh out loud
these are little quick short clips but
you're going to learn about insurance
and george is uh not only informative
but he's downright entertaining so be
sure and check this stuff out it's uh
the five-day guide to insurance
confidence in your coverage with george
campbell go to ramseysolutions.com
confidence and you'll start through the
artwork but you'll know more about
insurance
ramseysolutions.com
confidence canada is on the line
brittany's calling hi brittany welcome
to the ramsey show
hi dave how are you better than i
deserve what's up
oh my husband and i are 30 and 31 we've
been married for 10 years and we have a
two and a half year old daughter
um my question is about my parents
they're in their early 60s they have
absolutely no retirement plan they have
credit card debt they rent their house
they barely make ends meet my mom can't
work and my dad got laid off five years
ago from his sales job and has been
doing like food delivery and odd jobs
ever since and is sort of barely
squeezing by
we try to help but we have our own young
family to worry about
and i'm the only child who's able to
take care of them in the future so our
question is
what should we be doing to prepare for
the future when they need to retire
wow
um
well the only thing you can only the
strong can help the weak
broke people can't feed hungry kids
and if you're broke
and because you have a big fund over
here that says parents on the side of it
you have no other money and you haven't
taken care of yourself and you're
supposed to take care of them somehow in
your mind instead of your own family
um
then that doesn't work so your best
option is
do the stuff we teach
get yourself out of debt build your
emergency fund build some wealth and
become wealthy and the wealthier you are
by the time they need help the less
strain it's going to put on you if you
choose to help
them since they've not chosen to help
themselves how do you how does your
husband feel about this
he's equally as concerned about their
well-being as i am like of course our
family comes first but we would be the
only ones who could help them
to keep them off the street in the
future
sometimes that's code four i'm getting
ready to put my own family in stress
and i don't i'm not okay with that just
going to say it out loud
your babies and your husband and your
household are a 10 out of 10 on a
priority and your parents after their
misbehavior and lack of responsibility
and don't give a rip about anything and
choose to continue down this spending
like they're in congress are down the
list i i'm i mean i'm sympathetic
towards them i love for you to be able
to help them
but um
they're not real appealing people to
help
you know that's true
um and so
uh have you talked to them and said that
to them
no we're a bit nervous to talk to them
because we feel like they might be
defensive oh yeah i think
i'll bet they're defensive
yeah so we've we've tried to talk to
them but it doesn't seem like
they're it's
in denial no they're stuck on stupid
yeah i don't doubt that
wow i think there's some guilt and shame
on their part as well they're feeling
because they haven't taken care of
themselves and they've probably lost
hope that anything could even change and
so the only thing you can do is inject
some hope into their lives and that
doesn't mean you have to be soft it
might mean a really hard conversation
where you say you're broke and we can't
take care of you and i love you guys and
here's what it's going to take to get
out of this situation but i need you to
care more than i do
yeah
i mean it's like the only grown-up in
the equation i'm talking to is you
feels like that sometimes
i'm sorry
it feels like that sometimes yeah yeah
and it's it's frustrating gotta be
frustrating for you
um
so um yeah i mean i don't you don't have
to be mean or shaming to them that
doesn't serve any purpose no one is ever
transformed by somebody being mean to
them
i mean we do it here on the air because
it's just entertaining but the uh but
the truth is most people are transformed
more by love right and so sitting down
with them and just going mom and dad i'm
really scared for y'all and i'm i'm
honestly a little bit scared that uh
it's gonna put a strain on our family
because somehow i'm gonna be looked to
be the only one that takes care of y'all
cause you haven't take care of yourself
and um and
you know one more piece of honesty is
frustrates me a little bit i'm pretty
pretty upset with you about that
that you you you guys are a future
liability to me
because you won't behave
and so i really want you all to look
consider doing some stuff i'd love to
help you coach you i mean we're doing
some stuff we've gone through this class
i'll pay for you to go through this
class
um you know that kind of stuff and just
but there's no sense in shaming them but
it is also unfair for us all to walk
around and act like this is okay
if they were doing some other kind of
misbehavior you wouldn't tolerate it
i mean if they're doing cocaine you
wouldn't
well i just don't talk to them about it
i think they'll be defensive
you know you'd be going no that's you
know that's crazy y'all are doing
cocaine i mean you can't confuse love
with enabling and a lot of times people
go well this is the only way i know how
to love them is to give them money and
throw that at the problem yeah and i'm
that's what's being set up here it's not
there yet but it's being set up and and
it's it's as if you feel the obligation
to take care of somebody but well it's
sweet i i appreciate your sweetheart you
really have a good heart but i i do
think you owe them
a candid conversation about your fears
and your frustrations around this
subject
and that's not to shame them but that's
to let them in on the fact that they
should really and could really do some
things to help themselves and so that
they don't become a burden
um and
that's just frustrating
oh it's hard hannah's with us in
kingsport tennessee hi hannah how are
you
hi mr dave thank you for taking my call
sure what's up
um
my i'll just get my base question out on
the floor first my base question is
should i get a part-time or full-time
job while i get a personal business off
the ground i have three business ideas
that i'm in the middle of deciding among
although i've pretty much decided on
etsy
my husband's full-time income is about
84 to 90 000 take home a year
and he's doing he's doing contract work
so he's an engineer so we may or may not
be moving to florida or pennsylvania
next
uh our end goal is to adopt
and we don't want to have any debt when
we adopt we don't have any debt right
now but i count our mortgage as debt i
just i hate it it makes me feel sick
sometimes it is death um
excuse me it is debt mortgage is a debt
yes sir that's how i view it as well
i mean if you don't pay the house you
don't pay the payment they'll take the
house that's called debt yeah so
yeah but that's you know it's not i
don't want to be sick about it i want
you to be stressed out but well why
couldn't you work while you're starting
your etsy thing what's the downside
i'm hesitant because i have
some mental health issues they're not
super severe i don't have to be on
medication
but i have pretty severe anxiety that
can lead to panic attacks sometimes
depending on the work i do i also have
health issues that prohibits me from
being around chemicals so like i
couldn't work at a grocery store because
i'd have to use chemicals that
legitimately make me sick so sick like
wow
so are you getting some uh some therapy
some help on the anxiety issue
i have in the past i've been really
leaning into the lord and into my family
to help with the anxiety and
journaling for some reason has really
been helpful to you
it's very helpful it's a good tool yeah
i would just you know if you had any
other kind of illness a physical illness
you would get a doc
and you'd lean into the lord and family
on that too
and then you'd get a doctor that tells
you you need penicillin or you get a doc
that says you need to exercise or
whatever and
so if i were in your shoes i'd probably
try to get somebody to coach me on this
issue so that i can get this out of my
life um and see if you know get a good
christian counselor that the lord can
use to guide you and i think that'd be
helpful but yeah if you can find a
workplace that's chemical free and
doesn't trigger your anxiety issues
while you're working on them um i would
but i you know i'm fine with you not
doing that you can live on your
husband's income yeah it sounds like
it's not necessary but i would find some
work you can do even if from home and
get the etsy business off the ground is
at the pace that you can do it yeah and
i i would love to have the anxiety thing
under control and heading in the right
direction as we before we continue the
adoption process yeah and do that with
cash for sure
this is the ramsey show
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
george campbell ramsey personality is my
co-host today open phones at triple
eight eight two five five two two five
this is the ramsey show arena is with us
in portland oregon hi arena how are you
hi dave i am better than i deserve
good how can we help
uh thank you so much for taking my call
it's such an honor to speak with you
um so my husband and i are in baby steps
four five and six and i know that means
fifteen percent of total household
income um invested towards retirement
um i am wondering based on our situation
so we're pretty young we already have
about 27 000 for retirement which i made
me and my um husband then he was my
boyfriend um i made us invest that when
we were in high school
um and using the investment calculator
um so right now both of us are working i
recently graduated from college at freak
um and using the investment calculator i
saw that you know if i'm if we're
putting in a thousand each month then in
2055 when we want to retire at a 10
return we'll we'll have about 4 million
um which is
very very comfortable for us
um so i was wondering if it would be a
good idea to keep investing that 1000
which is about 15 of my income and then
we would use my husband 15 of his income
um and whatever else we can save apart
from uh for our kids and new car and
everything um to hopefully
to go towards the house and hopefully
pay that off soon so that later i can i
can
leave work raise the kids and yeah we
can continue to save that a thousand for
retirement and have some wiggle room uh
when we go back to just one salary
so let me recap you want to
invest seven and a half percent of your
household income to create wiggle room
to fund other life goals
effectively yes
no i would invest 15 total he invest 15
you invest 15. it doesn't matter how it
shakes down as long as it's 15 percent
of your household income and you guys
should have the margin to fund
everything else what's your number
what's your household income
um right now it'll be about 145 um with
uh before taxes okay well let me help
you with this
your um
assumptions
were that you kept investing the exact
same amount for your entire
and which life
assume that you made no more money
so you started at 145 and never got a
raise for 50 years
yeah not a realistic assumption agreed
yeah so so you're going to have more
than four million and you're going to
have the house paid off even quicker
than you thought
both
it's hard to see it with the numbers
because
um if we're um if we're investing 15 of
our total income it seems like it'll
take
well not it seems um running the numbers
it'll change how much do you owe on your
house
um
we have a loan out for i think around
300. okay
all right and so if you pay 30 000 a
year on the house in 10 years it's gone
right
and if you pay
50 000 a year on the house
out of 145
it's gone in what
six years
okay
so between six and seven years or
between six and ten years your home's
gonna be paid off how old are you
i'm 21 my husband's 23. he'll be 31.
oh ancient
i don't know how you're going to get
around when you're 31 be awful
but
honey you are doing so good
chill out and follow the baby steps
they work
you're going to be fine you're not only
going to get the house paid off before
you think you're going to you're going
to have more retirement than you think
you're going to
because you're going to get raises that
you didn't factor into your equation
and so when the math is talking to you
with the wrong assumptions it's telling
you the wrong things
okay yeah it was using that base number
just to see like
it's a good it's a good exercise to go
through but it's not a good exercise
it's not a good exercise to allow your
emotions to kick in because of
so
you know and listen did you hear what
you just said to me you're 22 years old
you guys make 145
000
you understand where that puts you
that's like rock star stuff you're
amazing
praise god
yeah you are you are some anxiety about
the future that you don't know she's
doing great listen you're just a
wonderful nerd is what you are yeah i
mean you just you love you love getting
in these numbers and bathing around
these numbers talk to you the fact
you're even thinking about the stuff and
talking about it you're amazing makes me
hurt you you are so wonderful you're
going to do so much better than your
feelings are telling you you're gonna do
uh because not because you worry and
fret but because you pay attention
and because you got an incredible
freaking start
at 22 yourself this is a good problem to
have so listen you invest 15 you still
have 85 percent of your gross income at
your disposal to accomplish all of your
life goals funding college paying off
the home early going on vacation
you guys are gonna be great you're gonna
be a millionaire when you're 30.
oh my gosh easy easy slam dunk hold on
i'm gonna send you a copy of baby steps
millionaires maybe it'll calm you down a
little bit you're doing great you are
doing so much better than you feel like
you're doing rex is in oklahoma city
what's up rex
hey guys how are you better than i
deserve how can we help
well okay so we're kind of getting in
this a little late in the game we're
both me and my wife we're both 45
ancient is the authorized kicked in yet
exactly
yes it has
anyway i mean we do well uh
we've got a we've got a mortgage
that we owe about 122
000 on houses worth close to 400. way to
go you almost got it done good
i know and that's what i've been
focusing on this you know
for the last 15 years how can we help
you today
what do you think well so we we've got
we've got about 90 000
and
i would i want to take that money
and throw it at the house
and what kind of savings just in your
savings account at the bank
it's just a bank well yeah
today
do you have you have an emergency fund
in addition to that
yes how much is in your emergency fund
thirty thousand
and you make how much a year
uh combined about 225.
okay yeah
yeah i mean take the 19th of it at the
house today and pay off the house by
christmas
that's what i want to do but my wife
she's a little more conservative and
she's like well tell her after you get
the house paid off if she hates it you
can go get a mortgage
okay so if she's conservative she'd want
the house mortgage gone well i i know
but she feels she's like i'm without
that money in the bank so you have an
emergency fund you have thirty thousand
dollars in a 225 000 income
is there something unstable about your
income
no
not at all she's a nurse i'm in sales
oh good lord yeah okay uh yeah she
listen i understand but what what i can
tell you is this is that
i would may i will make her a promise
that when she gets this house paid off
by christmas she's gonna sense
a security
that
is 10x what this 90k sitting in a stupid
savings account is giving her
here's why okay and i've just because
i've been doing this for so long and i
personally experienced it too but i've
witnessed it with debt free screamers
and talked to people all the time the
borrower is slave to the lender and what
we don't understand is what dr john
deloney talks about our body carries
the stress
of debt that we don't even know is there
because we've been carrying it so long
we're used to it
and when there's suddenly
it's over
and you got no payments anywhere
you suddenly i mean it's like it's like
somebody took 300 pounds off your
shoulders you stand up a little
straighter george you just paid off your
house you know back in january dr john
deloney said george you've been walking
around with a little swagger ever since
you paid off the house is that what
caused the swag that's all so much swag
didn't know that that's just why it's
but it's true
tell your wife you promise her that you
will be walking with a swagger when you
get your house paid off but no seriously
um
i'm telling you there's a thing that
happens in the in the physical and in
the spiritual because the borrower is
slave to the lender and when you are not
a slave anymore to citibank
or countrywide or whoever the flip it is
it changes things that you cannot put a
pencil to
and that don't show up necessarily
directly in the checkbook
but man you feel free
and i promise you her security is going
to be 10x
she's going to be glad she did it and if
you hate it you can always go get a
mortgage
this is the ramsay show
[Music]
[Music]
our scripture today john 15 5 i am the
vine you are the branches if you remain
in me and i in you you will bear much
fruit apart from me
you can do nothing
helen keller said we can do anything if
we stick to it long enough
open phones here at triple eight eight
two five five two two five george
campbell ramsey personality is my
co-host justin is in south bend indiana
hi justin how are you
i'm doing great dave it's a pleasure to
talk to you you too what's up
so my wife and i um
you know we are planning to build we're
trying to get on this housing
boom here and sell our home
and there's definitely a lot of things
that i was finishing up and i wanted to
make sure we were going to give somebody
a good home
so i had a lot of things i wanted to
finish make sure it was good to go and
now i kind of feel like we missed the
boat um house has been on the market for
about two weeks
ten days with a realtor um
so
no
activity at all and i just i'm very
concerned and i don't know what to do
from here um so when you sell it where
are you moving
uh so we're actually going to move in
with
my in-laws
we're going to end up building
and i'm going to do majority of that
myself so
sounds like a long journey
yeah yes it is
do the in-laws know that
yes
yes they do thankfully they're willing
to take us in
so how long does this project take do
you think
uh so it'll probably take at least a
good 10 to 12 months um
yeah okay and you're you're going to be
the general contractor
yeah i'm going to be the gc and i have a
few good friends that are going to help
me with a lot of electrical and plumbing
um so i'm hoping to save you know
quite a bit of money going that route
okay good that sounds fun
all right um so
uh you've had zero lookers
zero lookers one
yeah
what do you think not entirely
yeah you know what do you what do you
think is wrong with the house is the
price too high is it ugly
i don't think it's ugly personally i've
done most of the work so
um what is your realtor really good
uh she told us that we have really good
curb appeal she thought it was a good
home
and you know i guess what's really
discouraging is our neighbors next door
sold in four days this was about
four or five weeks ago now they sold in
about four days and what did a cell
phone ship definitely what is 303
3 000 and yours is listed for what yes
sir
290.
okay
and what was their square footage
uh it's 1100 i believe it was and yours
is
ours is 1800 including the finished
basement
so you have almost twice the size house
for less money and i've not had a single
looker
no sir
did your realtor actually put it in mls
is
is your real estate agent at ramsey elp
i don't know apparently not okay can you
hire the other the neighbors realtor
because clearly they did a good job
uh yeah i definitely could look into
that i guess um
that's why i'm calling you because i
don't know exactly what
the problem is i don't either i mean
i'm hearing more i'm hearing a better
buy i mean you're 75 cents on the dollar
per square foot of the house next door
um and you're almost twice as large and
you're for less money
i mean it's there's nothing i hear that
did you get professional photos done was
it staged properly
yeah we got professional photos done um
you're not you're not you're not under
construction on any of your projects
no sir no but that's why we kind of
listed it i feel a little late because i
want to make sure everything was done
i mean the market didn't in the last two
weeks the market in south bend indiana
didn't just stop
that just didn't happen okay
yeah so something else is going on i
don't know what it is but i mean
the real estate market has slowed down
versus three months ago
but um but your neighbor's sale
indicates the market's still fairly
lively
yeah
yeah so i don't know i don't know what
to tell you the real estate agent has no
idea they've got no input
uh no they were at a loss as well um
and we're just kind of at a standstill
and i just i'm not sure if we should
lower the price or keep it the same or
no i don't think i mean if if the house
next door is any kind of comparable sale
at all
i mean if it's any indicator you're not
overpriced agreed okay
i don't think price is the problem here
i think we need to look into the other
factors with the real estate agent and
really start to make some tweaks and see
if it changes the ball the ball game at
all yeah i mean it's only been two weeks
that's not bad only takes one buyer but
oh my goodness um
yeah that yeah i'm with you it's a
little bit uh i i'm not freaking out
that the overall economy has completely
fallen in the dumper since your
neighbor's house sold 14 days ago and
you you missed the one little moment in
time you could have sold your house it's
not that's just not true that's not that
didn't happen okay so but the market is
slowing and there is lots of bad
economic news on the tv but that does
not mean suddenly all the buyers went
away they did not
people are selling houses like crazy out
there
so um all across america to this day so
i don't i don't know i i that's
interesting
um
there's something in this conversation i
don't know that there's a piece of
information i'm missing that's that i
just don't think lowering it by five
grand is gonna no it's seven no i would
not lower the price i might change the
real estate agent if they can't if they
have absolutely no input
i mean if your real estate agent sold 50
60 houses last year
they would you know i'm afraid you've
got a new a newbie
but if you don't have a newbie if you've
got a stud that's the high octane that's
doing a lot of work then maybe we'll
just give a little time let's let it sit
and watch watch it a little bit and see
but
that's a little weird i don't disagree
with you strange
strange if you want to get the part
people that we recommend they're called
ramsey trusted endorsed local providers
these are all high octane high
performers sell a lot of houses or they
don't get in our program we will not
endorse somebody that doesn't do a lot
of volume and if you want to find out
who that is just click on that call them
and ask them for an opinion you just
call them talk to them click on them at
ramseysolutions.com and elp for real
estate and you know you put in your zip
and your street address and all that
kind of junk and it'll pop right up and
give you a couple different people to
pick from in your area
david is with us in tucson hi david
welcome to the ramsey show
thank you gentlemen and i know time's
short so i'll jump straight to it good
uh
doing retirement income planning on old
assumptions and all of a sudden some of
those assumptions are changing so my
plan has always been to wait till 70 for
social security
for the 8 per year boost and
my full retirement age is about two
months away and suddenly i realized with
inflation
colas aren't likely to be one or two
percent they're likely to be six to
eight percent which pretty much makes up
the difference
i can also i'm still working i can
divert up to 27 000 a year into a
traditional 457b
as we discussed earlier today you can
buy that on sale
uh social security is only taxable at 85
percent instead of 100 yeah so your
question am i missing something or is it
time to do your questions
what are you wanting to do
am i missing something or
does retire or claiming social security
at full retirement age just make more
sense than it ever did
social security now instead of 70
because the economy's down right now
well the cola makes up the
loss of maybe waiting for the delayed
credit yeah maybe if it didn't if it
doesn't adjust it
more
i mean coal coal is not out yet on the
and and it's usually not good it's going
to self-correct over
time uh because your inflation rate
hopefully is not going to stay at this
because i don't believe
that we're going to leave people in
office that continue to do the stupid
but stuff that they're doing
so um
yeah i um
no
no
i don't i think you i think your
original plan is the plan you stick with
um i because i don't think you're going
to see the inflation numbers stay up
there long enough to make sure your plan
activates the way you're talking about
your new plan activates the way you're
talking about so i think your old plan
is just fine
i i again i
try not to make permanent decisions on
temporary data
and that's what this feels like but hey
thanks for the call it's an interesting
question yeah george good show today
appreciate it austin penn zach andrew
james in the booth well done gentlemen
i am dave ramsey your host we'll be back
with you before you know it in the
meantime remember there's ultimately
only one way to financial peace and
that's to walk daily with the prince of
peace christ jesus
[Music]
do you love a good dave rant want to see
the latest ramsay show videos going
viral check out your favorite moments
from the ramsay show on youtube go watch
and subscribe to the ramsay show channel
on youtube
[Music]
you